les amis aujourd'hui on avec maxence et
on va jouer un jeu bonjour maxence
souviens très bien vrai ça suffit ce jeu
l'achat pour le bien-être de cette vidéo
on arrive au niveau des charges et qui
s'appelle l'ia douaty on contrôle un
personnage qui va avancer en fonction du
bruit qu'on fait il avance quand on
parle quand il ya du bruit
le gall fort plus haut sera au voilà
vous êtes tous compris c'était horrible
parce que j'ai dû gueuler et je me suis
fait écorcher mal c'est vrai mais pas
c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui
avance très vite dans la flore et et
tombe sur un loup il se fait manger là
jean berthon pleurer chez maman ça fait
quand même mal que ce faire tous couper
la jambe à la la qu'est-ce que ça fait
mal je sais j'ai mangé par toujours mon
dieu c'est terrible pour désinfecter et
en sortant du bus avait agressé par un
autre homme qui lui mord dallas j'ai
envie de partage sa deuxième chance est
alors qu'il foulait e maurice orthez les
choses quand un mois des liens dans ce
cas révèle qu'ils mangent en bois non
mérités trois morts
de tatakoto ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta faut le brûler sa fausse en servir
comme allume-feu poumon
a laissé sa voix grave mais vraiment
bien sûr nous voilà génial
ouvrir sa ligne d'arrivée d'un certain
sens et demi mais je peux pas te dire
parce que je découvre avancée du tyran
clients suivants youtube heures suivant
pour la vidéo des eaux prochain devenir
sa femme un mot aulas et ça lui aura
coûté la vie tu permets que ses carnets
je m'appelle florent pagny ça lui va
bien c'est un français blanc bonnet s'il
fait le flou la banio paniqué c'est quoi
je vais aux toilettes je reviens je te
laisse te north america
[Musique]
1 et
[Rires]
les coaches pasqua
[Musique]
j'aurais jamais pensé ouvrir bail je
pensais que servant l'objet destiné à
pas de faire m'arrête du tout de ta vie
[Musique]
et la mort et à la boîte à bien on
étudie ce que c'est
dis-moi jamie qu'est-ce qui se trouvent
aux abords d'une boîte à meuh watts
voilà ce qui est morte et un anneau avec
un truc en métal voilà et du coup ça
fait ce bruit là d'accord je sais que ça
va les flaques d'eau on va tout
simplement parce que en fait il veut
aller claquer dont les doigts rien je
vais
[Musique]
deux doigts si je peux me permettre à
deux claques mais pourquoi pas ces deux
traits que je fais péter du monde moyens
c'est alors qu'est ce que c'est non mais
attends que jose déjà j'avais pas
compris au début je me sens super bien
je vais devoir faire nos devoirs le
bruit qui fait pas mal au bout de 6 mois
à temps il ya bien finir ce mec c'est
ultra tu touches à peine ça pète
à peine le tout serait papa papa papa
papa papa papa papa
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap
ap ap ap ap ap le
mais je suis tellement heureux que tu
sois là on rentre sponsors désir est
battu et ça fait cher voilà on n'a pas
lancé jeu de cordée a fait savoir que
j'ai la tête qui tombe c'est pas toi est
ce qu'on met pas en train de faire un
truc hyper pas recommandé que ces genres
il ya déjà des articles surtout ne
faites pas ça allait choquer la main ce
qu'elle avance de votre caisse à croire
à ce coffret
j'ai plus des liens de la bombarde et
sur la voirie la tentation attention
vous savez que vous allez réussir on
oublie la galerie aggravant lui saute
dessus comme dans mario il doit mourir
with music man il faut car [ __ ] mais
le bruit du ballon et l'a fait tomber
ça va mon pote tu vas pas tomber dans
les pommes
bon tu as tué mon survêt lundi d'un
super aller bosser
geof jamais bossé et là d'un coup ma
faim nous crée des mois que je suis pas
trop quoi ce que je suis pas tombé et on
a réussi parce que dans la vie quand tu
réagirais m'a dit ah j'étais chaud là
j'étais choses étaient bien franchement
c'est bien on salue la performance a
bloqué j'ai tendance à flancher
j'ai tendance à flotter blocage étant
ensemble
[Musique]
jamais autant joué les sens du jeu le
lancement avec gt gt1 fallait que j'aide
havlat car des plus beaux au monde les
amis alors l'analyse continue avec
maxence mecque et ça faisait longtemps
que je n'étais pas éclater gaza d'une
vidéo ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas
autant je suis et c'est tout ce qu'on va
mettre faire les dix premières années de
notre vie est bon on l'a fait on s'est
dit avec toi et j'invite joie hélium
bruit de train un petit truc de cambrai
n'hésitez pas à mes lèvres dans ça vous
a plu à elle passée voir la chaîne de
maxence vous y trouverez l'explication
de cette coupe de cheveux est entre
autres à travailler dans une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien
[Musique]
ça
oh